ami and Daryl Jennings say their home
was the only one spared in their
neighborhood as a tornado brought
widespread destruction their home east
of the city of Nashville became a
shelter that's all you could hear is
just people screaming throughout the
neighborhood and we ended up with a
house full of muddy people in their
pajamas was terrified we became the
collection point because we were the
only house standing dozens of people
were killed in their homes across
Tennessee the youngest was just two
years old in the capital of country
music in the u.s. celebrities took to
social media to voice their support to
those that really lost family members
sorry about that and our prayers are
with you and so just wanted to shout out
and say we're with you schools prisons
and airports were also damaged neighbors
here say they're relying on each other
to get back on their feet one of the
little girls is the ones next door she
said I don't want to leave the house
that stayed up and that just I was like
that's why our house stayed up because
they needed a place to go the tornadoes
were the worst to hit Tennessee in seven
years and it remains in a state of
emergency
Leah Hardin al-jazeera